Roderick is with us in Pittsburgh hey
Robert how are you I'm doing well how
are you better than I deserve what's up
well it's in a nutshell my wife and I
are planning a move to start our careers
she is graduating you know about a month
or so but we both have a substantial not
a student loan debt the neighborhood of
well over $600,000 $600,000 yes well
over it we're both positions large so
they're freaking brain surgeons what's
your schedule elation I'm feeling
medicine see psychiatry oh my lord
all right uh these are not exactly
high-paying fields
how'd you get six hundred grand in depth
of that well I personally I came from a
single-parent household I had to pay for
college graduate school and medical
school so good alone and life also took
out still in loans to pay for graduate
school and medical school so what do you
project your incomes to be first year um
well for residency we're starting our
income will be about combined about a
hundred and eight thousand dollars a bit
better and when you get on reservation
say what do you predict you're
comfortable right when we gather our
residency you should at least triple if
not quadruple I think we both make in
the neighborhood of about two hundred
thousand to start each we have a lot of
family behind or not well income has
increased significantly for failing
medicine power over here no none okay I
work with a lot of talks all the time
they don't 100 hash what you're looking
at probably less you get an unusual
gigas I'm kind of you can get 200 I'm
not going to be mad at you you need it
because you sure have a dadgum huge mess
on your hands right what and it will
mass oh yeah so you guys need to live
like college students until this is gone
I don't care what your income is you
know I and not going to so the question
that I had was in tons of this debt
it I guess conceivable to consider it as
more of a mortgage in terms of debt when
you consider the baby steps acreage but
I wouldn't consider it a mortgage no you
need to clear it up a few years okay you
know you're making four hundred you need
to live on 50 and clear it up in two
years right and that will goes what does
definitely the plan we don't plan to buy
a house or anything until we clear up in
the hallways of the parlors
how would you consider the mortgage if
you're paying it off and well your
shower
we were thinking in terms with baby
steps and sort of the first game those
now has been paying off that and then
building up emergency fund
so we allocate is available only for
making it four hundred thousand dollars
a year or three hundred thousand dollars
a year you're not going to need much of
an emergency fund all right and I'm just
talking about starting this year because
I making that much money isn't until
about year one or five so that's one of
that's what's scaring me here yeah you
need to live on nothing and pay
everything above nothing towards this
disaster you need to be in panic mode
dude I mean I can't breathe and it's not
even my dad six hundred and seventy
thousand dollars rather day and you're
just nonchalant about it he want you
operating on me unbelievable oh man what
a mess yeah you need to really really
focus on living on nothing no house
buying no car buying no vacations no
eating out and completely focus on
cleaning up this mess to do this is if
you do not do that you're going to be in
debt for decades if you're not careful
here I'm so sorry
what a horrible thing to be facing I
can't imagine how overwhelming that must
feel or should feel hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]